[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
we're getting closer and closer to that
day on which we celebrate America's
independence and all of that stuff it's
called the 4th of July and it's I don't
know it's just a day for barbecues for
me I don't get super patriotic on that
day Pat I mean I'm not even American but
it's still a fun day to hang out with
friends and to do some grilling of all
sorts of things vegan and otherwise yeah
aren't you on the record saying that
you're not even a fan of fireworks like
that's pretty anti-american if I do say
so myself
fireworks are absolutely disgusting and
despicable and I think that they are
destroying the fabric and corseting the
culture of our nation completely and
they're also just really really annoying
but in any case Donald Trump is making a
big deal out of the 4th of July there's
going to be a big salute to America on
the National Mall and the plans have now
been released and there's going to be
music there will be military
demonstrations and flyovers which you
know the flyover by itself is a common
fixture at sporting events and I don't
like it like it's too militaristic for
me the idea of combining a sporting
event with you know such a brazen
display of the military the fruits of
the military industrial complex the
flyover I already sort of don't like but
military demonstrations in Washington DC
for me are just the calling cards of
authoritarians well we couldn't disagree
more so far I love flyovers they give me
the chills
I love anticipating them and then it's
over before you know it I get this cool
feeling when I see a flyover but I feel
like if I lived around a sporting arena
and I didn't know that they were gonna
do a flyover that day and I was just
hanging out in my apartment and I heard
the planes fly overhead I would be
absolutely terrified because I would
think that there was a nuclear bomb
coming to get me yeah well we disagree
on that I don't like the flyovers but
then some of the other things that will
be taking place at Donald Trump's 4th of
July event will include marching bands a
drum corps floats military units giant
balloons equestrian drill teams there
will be flag waving groups you will also
see Donald Trump lead a celebration of
America with music and
military demonstration and fly over
there will also be a spectacular
fireworks display over the National Mall
and those fireworks will be launched
from right behind the Lincoln Memorial
which will be an extraordinarily
stunning visual and of course this is
all being taken advantage of by Donald
Trump in a sort of in conjunction with
the launch of his re-election campaign
and I mean listen I I just I have such a
negative reaction to this stuff I don't
know exactly what it is it's not an
anti-american sentiment it's just the
kind of constant politicizing of and
glorification of elements of our society
that I just don't think should be
glorified for political gain yeah and I
think Donald Trump was inspired to do
this when he went to France a couple
summers ago he witnessed their Bastille
Day celebrations that went on for hours
and hours and I think if they did if we
had a celebrations here that went on for
hours and hours I would certainly get
bored but apparently Trump was not bored
yeah and he wanted one of his owners at
home yeah
hours and hours and hours and of course
who benefits from this Trump because
he's launching his reelection bid also
because the guy has a hotel on unfenced
vania Avenue and that Hotel is already
sold out for the entire fourth of July
weekend which of course benefits Trump
he's going to be profiting off of the
celebration delightful well Trump is
profiting almost from almost everything
that he does in this presidency and that
we shouldn't expect that to be any
different with this so on the 4th of
July I'm canceling the 4th of July David
Pakman show break right now we were
gonna do shows the entire fourth of July
break in order to prevent to take
attention away from these celebrations
okay I'll cancel my plans then that's
nice
by all means cancel them immediately no
we are we are going to be off for like
six months just in celebration of the of
the 4th of July no I'm kidding well
we'll just take a couple days off as we
always do and it'll combine with the
weekend then it'll be like a very lovely
four or five day five-day weekend okay
surgeons are often considered within the
medical world as sort of the mechanics
they are not known for their bedside
manner they are known for the physical
skill of performing the types of
surgeries that they perform and often
there they are not necessarily the
easiest to get along with even for their
co-workers which could be operating room
staff or nurses or others and there's a
new study published this week in the JMA
surgery Journal which says that when the
interactions between surgeons and their
teams are unprofessional or abrasive or
whatever that their end up being more
complications after surgery and this is
like completely obvious once we if
you've read there's a really great book
called the checklist manifesto by Atul
Gawande who's a surgeon I believe he is
at an endocrinology a surgical
endocrinology oncologist or oncology
endocrinology basically endocrinology
cancers in the Boston area and if you've
read that book you would immediately
understand that something like an
abrasive surgeon running operations
would affect the people around the
surgeon and would lead to worse health
outcomes for the patient and now we
actually have a study confirming that
but completely unsurprising Pat yes so
an example of something like that
happening would be a nurse makes a
recommendation that maybe is a bad
recommendation for example in the
surgeon yells at her yeah now the nurse
is less likely to give a recommendation
in the future and maybe in the future
she would have some great recommendation
something important to the patient that
she just keeps to herself because she
doesn't want to get yelled at again and
so that leads to complications down the
road I feel like with this study maybe
like the methodology as in isn't quite
the best because you're dealing with
employees reporting and kind of telling
on the surgeons right but I think it's
the best that we can do and it looks
like they were actually able to glean
some some concrete results from it like
over a 36 month period after a surgery
patients were 12 to 14 percent more
likely to experience complications if
they had an embrace of surgeon and that
include things like infections pneumonia
stroke and kidney failure so this is all
serious business
you know it's not just purely the
surgeons abilities
for my procedure it's also how they act
with the people around them it's
interesting that when you talked about a
nurse
you said she yeah I know I picked up on
that too I mean listen this is that we
when we talk about in the in the
discussion about the gender pay gap one
of the examples that's often cited is
men are more likely to be surgeons are
more likely to be men and nurses are
more likely to be women and there are
obviously arguments that are based on
that that some are good arguments some
are bad arguments but that's actually
something that often comes up in the
discussion about the gender pay gap well
it's weird though like should I go out
of my way to say that the surgeon is
female and that the nurse is male just
because no that is that is less likely
to happen but certainly that's a
paradigm that can happen and so should I
try police my language in that sense
like of course you need to say he or she
in either yes right you could say the
surgeon in the nurse I had another
slip-up actually recently talking to a
friend of mine who is half Puerto Rican
and I asked when her grandparents
immigrated here oh no and that was bad
of course because Puerto Rico is a part
of the United States before ever reason
just thinking through that during that
conversation I didn't recognize that
Puerto Rico's party united states so
immigrate is of course not the right
word so I think I'm gonna just like sit
in a hole for a little while get woke
study up on some things and then I'll
come back on the bonus show next week
more prepared someone was mad about
there was something you said when was it
that we did this totally derail when was
it that we did the story about the
password security and facial recognition
somebody wrote to me couple days ago
yeah somebody wrote to me I didn't
remember if it was the last Friday or
Monday somebody wrote to me and said
yeah I was cringing when Pat was talking
about Apple did facial recognition and
then canceled it or something like that
and I didn't even really understand what
it was that they were mad about but they
didn't like something about what you
said yeah I saw the reddit post about
that to someone said that we sounded
very misinformed which could have
totally been true but they didn't
clarify exactly what we were wrong about
kind of left confused and not knowing
how to improve myself I was equally
confused and I would like more feedback
about that one of the Sandy Hook victims
fathers has won a defamation suit
against Alex Jones
who has now been sanctioned I'm talking
about Leonard Posner whose six-year-old
son was killed at the Sandy Hook
massacre and he's been fighting
conspiracy theorists including Alex
Jones for a long time and he finally
scored a win this week against deniers
who have been saying that the entire
thing never happened and a Wisconsin
judge issued a summary judgment in his
favor in a defamation lawsuit against
the authors of a book called nobody died
at Sandy Hook which is a book that has
all sorts of false claims claiming that
the entire shooting was a FEMA drill it
was all a pretext to justify the
confiscation of guns that there were
crisis actors and all sorts of other
stuff and the lawsuit was very narrowly
focused in on the claim by James Fetzer
and Mike Palecek
that Posner had forged or faked the
death certificate of his kid though it
also alluded to other conspiracy
theories and the court documents say
that the authors acted with malice that
they knowingly published statements that
they knew to be false or that at least
had reckless disregard for whether they
were true or false false and ultimately
this is a win for reason and reality and
this is also connected to a whole bunch
of other issues related to this
including motions to sanction Alex Jones
because there's a separate defamation
lawsuit against Alex Jones also a
defamation lawsuit along the same lines
and a Connecticut judge has sanctioned
Alex Jones for what she called a
despicable tirade against the attorney
representing the families of the victims
of the Sandy Hook shooting we talked
about this earlier this week Jones
launched into this sware laced tirade
claiming that child porn had been
planted on infowar servers and all sorts
of unsubstantiated allegations and now
he has been sanctioned so I think that
this is good news right Pat yeah I mean
I hope something like this doesn't
happen again where we have a terrible
incident of mass shooting of course I
don't want that alone to happen but then
later on people to make up bogus
conspiracy theories about it that really
do
impact the victims of the tragedy and
the family members of the victims of the
tragedy so I hope that this is an
example and something that stops it from
happening in the future
funny enough Alex Jones's excuse his
legal argument with all this stuff is
that he was experiencing a form of
psychosis right shortly after the Sandy
Hook shooting a Fuchs and yeah and that
he thought that everything was staged
and I I can't believe that people are
still listening to Alex Jones when he's
coming out there and saying that like
the guys saying that he's he was
psychotic and somehow his viewers are
able to put that behind him maybe maybe
that they think that he's no longer
experiencing psychosis maybe they'd like
him anyway that would be that he's
saying things that are equally
ridiculous now I mean again he's saying
that there was porn planted possibly by
the the attorney who was involved with
the suit against him that they may have
planted child porn on his computer he's
saying when I said things that are
completely not based in reality a few
years ago I was in some kind of
psychotic fugue state but now he's
saying things that are equally baseless
but are we supposed to believe that he's
no longer in that fugue state yeah and
then also a couple years back when Jones
was dealing with the child custody
lawsuit
I think his lawyers argue that he was
just playing a character on his show so
if you're an avid ouch Jones viewer you
have to deal with those things you have
to deal with the fact that he's either
psychotic or he's playing a character
whatever the reason is I think there's
plenty of justification to provide that
he's not actually as genuine self heir
at least that he's just way over
exaggerating for the purposes of
entertainment yeah I mean I think that
the character thing that there is
actually a serious discussion to be had
there like for example on the david
packard show this is basically a show
where i just give my genuine opinion
about politics and the things i say on
the show are real when i tell a story
about something that happened to me it's
a real story when i give my opinion
about what i think someone should or
shouldn't do that's really how I feel
and if it were to become a court
transcript of sorts those truly would be
my feelings and views about things at
the same time for example with the Sam
cedar set controversy and lawsuits and
all of this stuff it's all fake like
we're both pretending that were really
mad at each other and that there's legal
action and all
the stuff if that was presented in some
kind of court thing I would rightly say
that is a character in the sense that
none of that is real it's all theater
and and most of the audience gets it but
not everybody yeah it's weird how not
everyone gets that I wish everyone could
just understand your humor there but
unfortunately they don't yes yeah but
like Jones isn't known to play a
character within a character and to be
just totally joking around with stuff
during his show he like gives this uh
this idea that he's always being serious
and believing everything that he says
and yeah I mean sometimes I play
different characters on this show or the
bonus show like I've been known to be
I've known to be bushy-tailed wide-eyed
Pat and also been a devil's advocate Pat
right
you need a guy up on the subway Pat yeah
and my whole thing is if it later comes
out that I said something completely
stupid or deplorable then I was just
playing a character then I was just
joking around yet if I'm giving eloquent
informed points then that's me that's
the actual version of me yeah earlier
this week you were playing a character
you were playing a producer who doesn't
know anything about facial recognition
yet earlier in this bonus show I was
actually playing a producer who is not
so woke on the sort of pronouns that
you're supposed to use when talking
about certain professions yes and you
know maybe if people don't want me to
play that character again I'll stop
doing it yeah there's a lot of
disagreement about which version of
producer Pat people liked the most but I
think in either case you've never
claimed that any of these characters
were in any way related to a psychotic
or fugue state no and I think that's our
next poll question which version of
producer Pat do you like the best and
what topic will a Pat eventually go so
far off the rails on that he will claim
he was in some kind of fugue state
reminiscent of that really great episode
in Breaking Bad of course I don't know
what it would take for you to do that I
mean I'm always willing to issue an
apology though that I'm always wish okay
one more time this is always Pat up in
two it's not really working for him here
I'm always willing to issue an apology
to those whom I have offended yes
and that is a very very large list of
people so we will get started on those
apologies submit your name if you demand
an apology from up from Purdue keypad
that does it for today
new show new bonus show tomorrow the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]